foreign
[Music]
this morning Lee and Andrew child and
the future of Jack Reacher Reacher is
one of the most famous characters in all
of books a gigantic ex-military cop
turned wandering investigator and
pugilist since Lee Child published his
first Reacher book in 1997 the series
has sold more than 100 million copies
there have been movies starring Tom
Cruise and now a TV show but a few years
ago Lee Child realized he was running
out of gas so he hatched a plan to allow
Jack Reacher to live on
you always started books on the
anniversary of you getting fired well it
was the anniversary that I first sat
down to write the first book first of
September Lee Childs started writing
Jack Reacher in his early 40s after
getting downsized out of his job in
production in British television his
brother Andrew was his first reader back
then you know Lee was out of work and
when he sent me the manuscript to read I
was terrified for two reasons because I
thought what if it's terrible I'm the
one who's going to have to go to my
brother and say sorry your book sucks
you know time to go and work at the
grocery store he would as well but then
the other thing I was thinking was well
if it does suck and no one will buy it
then what am I going to do I'll have to
send him food Parcels or you know let
him sleep in my spare room or something
so it was the most nerve-wracking read
I've ever I've ever had nerves were
quickly calmed Lee's first Reacher novel
Killing Floor in 1997 was a hit and
launched a global franchise that has led
to 27 books two movies you're gonna be
wearing these cuffs on your way to
prison well that is one magnificent
prophecy Mr Reacher just thinking maybe
my brother told me about blind Blake for
a reason and an Amazon streaming series
I guess I'll find everybody responsible
kill every last one of them
but there was always going to be an end
right
infuriated me when you would get into a
great series and then you would sense
that the author was getting old or tired
or running out of gas running out of
energy and the quality fell away and
this thing that you had relied on all
these years was suddenly no good anymore
and so when I started writing I made
myself a promise I would never do that I
would try and look ahead and sense the
point where I was going to run out of
energy and get out rather than
disappoint my readers that was the plan
but the readers love Reacher it ruins up
the beans automatically in them Lee said
he had a running fantasy where he could
drink a magic potion and turn 15 years
younger
thankfully for him Andrew is 14 years
younger both are writers Andrew has
written nine Thrillers under the
brothers given last name Grant
both were deeply impacted by a difficult
childhood in England I felt like a fish
out of water in my family I was
completely different than anybody else
literally to the point where I assumed I
was a changeling mixed up at the
hospital and the wrong kid brought home
and I lived with that feeling for you
know probably 15 20 years until Andrew
was born and then developed enough tiny
personality of his iron as a toddler I
suddenly realized no wait a minute there
is something about this genetic thing he
is like me and for me it was the same
experience except looking looking in the
other direction because I had exactly
the same feeling of being a fish out of
water and so when I would look and see
that he was like me and he had escaped
and was living a normal life it gave me
hope
did you ever imagine you'd take over
reach her not in a million years now I
mean when when Lee suggested that it was
an absolute shock was this your C this
was your secret plan like long before
you told him it was uh it was a
developing plan yeah in 2020 the first
double bylined Reacher came out the
Sentinel about to be released the third
team efforts called no plan B
by now Andrew does most of the writing
and though he plans to keep what has
made the famously stoic anti-technology
Reacher characters so appealing he does
say he wants to bring him into a
slightly more modern future everybody
knows Rachel they know what he's about
and they don't want that to
fundamentally change you know we don't
want reach of becoming a tree-hugging
vegetarian but at the same time you
don't you know you've got to make it
different enough to keep it interesting
there's so many Thrillers that are being
written constantly is it is it the
language that's always separated Reacher
in your books you are actually creating
a thing that is is like a huge long poem
where every word is correctly Chosen and
every syllable in fact tips the reader
into the next syllable so that the
momentum becomes Unstoppable the way you
talk about sentence structure that gives
me goosebumps yeah well it's one of
those things that is it's like the
suspension on your car you know you
don't want the passenger to know
anything about it or just feel it
working or to see it working all the
passenger goes is a smooth fast right
but underneath all that stuff is working
like crazy a few years ago Lee and
Andrew both moved to Southeast Wyoming
on the edge of Colorado
Lee's house sits on 35 Acres of former
Ranch Land Andrews is just a mile down
the road
aside from Building a garage for their
car collection in a nearby ghost town
they now own
they're also putting up a brand new
writing building it's not going to be a
shared office it's going to be like a
symmetrical building with his end and my
end this landscape is epic it is heroic
and the climate is heroic a Fitting
Place for Jack Reacher to get to know
his new father
or better said brother who feels more of
a burden right now
it's got to be him uh because you know
the future structures I had for him for
me and in a lot of ways my job is done
and how does that pressure sit with you
well you know I think pressure is a
great thing honestly you know you have
to have something that pushes you to
always do your best plus we have a
phrase we're from A Hard Scrabble town
in England called Birmingham we say I'm
from Birmingham I'm not afraid of stress
stress is afraid of me
I like it wow so the plan was for them
to work on four books together sort of
with Andrew doing more and more of the
work and then for Andrew to take it over
entirely after those four but things are
changing you never know seems like Lee
has it's like this revitalization almost
with Andrew working and so maybe now he
stays longer I think he feels energized
by the fact that he's able to work with
his brother and they can spend time
together and talk about the character
that's sweet though but I thought I
detected a little eyeball when he was
talking about where he wanted to take
into the future there was a slight
little bit was I wrong there did you
notice that I don't know maybe maybe a
little a little
yeah really cool though and talking
about how they both felt like outcasts
almost from the family yeah that was
interesting
how difficult that was for them I got a
little over clamped hearing that it's
nice to know they found it they have
that Bond yeah